bienvenidos de nuevo a Quantum Computing in practice soy tu anfitriona Olivia Lanes la última vez vimos un ejemplo de un
enfoque de computación cuántica para un problema de optimización conocido como Max Cut usando la formulación QUBO, llegamos
bastante lejos en profundidad pero eso fue solo un ejemplo de un enfoque hoy vamos a hablar de aplicaciones a corto plazo
de forma más amplia y desarrollar nuestra intuición sobre los distintos tipos de problemas en los que esperamos encontrar soluciones cuánticas útiles
y ver algunos ejemplos recientes de trabajos importantes realizados en nuestra comunidad a escala de
utilidad anteriormente mencionamos brevemente que no todos los problemas necesitan potencia computacional adicional
específicamente computación cuántica para resolverse de manera eficiente estos son los problemas que ya conoces mejor
aritmética, desplazarte por redes sociales, quizás jugar al Tetris, Doom u otros videojuegos los consideramos en general
problemas fáciles por otro lado hay problemas muy difíciles como encontrar los factores primos de números
enteros enormes y esta es la base del cifrado RSA y lo que el algoritmo de Shor fue diseñado para resolver otro
ejemplo es encontrar una solución en un conjunto de datos sin ordenar esto en teoría puede resolverse con el algoritmo cuántico conocido
como el algoritmo de Grover sin embargo la mayoría de los expertos coinciden en que este tipo de algoritmos requerirán la
implementación de corrección de errores y tecnológicamente aún no estamos ahí así que a medida que avancemos en esta
lección y en tu viaje educativo cuántico recuerda que buscamos ese punto óptimo en algún lugar aquí en el medio
es un problema difícil de resolver pero eso también es lo que lo hace tan divertido algo que todavía no hemos discutido
mucho es la teoría de la complejidad computacional una de las razones es que puede ser algo intimidante y sí,
compleja la teoría de la complejidad computacional es el campo de la informática que busca clasificar los problemas computacionales
según su dificultad hay una gran cantidad de clases de complejidad distintas en la computación clásica pero las más
fundamentales son los problemas P estos son problemas que pueden resolverse en tiempo polinomial y escalan a medida que el
problema aumenta lo que significa que son fáciles de resolver el siguiente tipo de problema, más difícil, son los problemas NP que
significa polinomial no determinista estos son problemas cuyas respuestas pueden verificarse en tiempo polinomial pero no
necesariamente resolverse el siguiente es NP-completo y aquí nos adentramos en los problemas realmente difíciles sin
solución polinomial conocida aquí es donde viven problemas famosos como el problema del viajante e incluso el juego
del Sudoku ahora bien, cuando surgió la computación cuántica al menos en teoría, la gente dedicó un esfuerzo considerable a intentar
descubrir qué clase de problemas estos nuevos tipos de ordenadores serían capaces de resolver eficientemente una nueva clase de
problemas fue inventada llamada problemas cuánticos polinomiales de error acotado o BQP para abreviar su definición estricta es un
poco larga pero es la clase de problemas de decisión resolubles por un ordenador cuántico en tiempo polinomial con una pequeña
probabilidad de error hay una probabilidad de error porque la medición cuántica es inherentemente aleatoria pero el error
puede hacerse arbitrariamente pequeño ahora bien todas estas clases viven en una clase más amplia que llamamos PSPACE y aquí es donde
creemos que vive BQP en relación con todos los demás tipos de problemas pero es muy difícil demostrar esto de forma definitiva
matemáticamente notarás que los problemas cuánticos BQP no se superponen necesariamente con los problemas NP-completos
sin embargo puede que hayas visto algunos enfoques de computación cuántica que buscan resolver problemas NP-completos ¿por qué
sería esto? un malentendido común es que no tiene sentido explorar soluciones
a problemas como el del viajante y otros problemas NP-completos para un ordenador cuántico o cualquier problema en el que no se haya
encontrado una prueba matemática de una ventaja cuántica sin embargo esto no tiene por qué ser necesariamente así
encontrar una prueba matemática de que un algoritmo cuántico es más rápido que su contraparte clásica es algo poco común Shor y
Grover son dos de los únicos pocos ejemplos en los que esto se ha logrado hasta ahora pero eso está bien de hecho los científicos
informáticos aún no han podido demostrar que las clases P y NP sean diferentes aunque toda la intuición
nos dice que deben serlo además, comparar dos algoritmos y cómo escalan a menudo analiza el peor caso
para cada uno es bastante posible que en la práctica el peor caso no sea lo que encontramos en la vida real así que
no hay que desanimarse en cambio introducimos la idea de soluciones heurísticas si eres una persona
experimentalista ya conoces y aprecias este tipo de soluciones una heurística es cualquier enfoque para resolver un
problema que es pragmático pero no necesariamente óptimo y eso está bien porque las soluciones no tienen por qué
ser óptimas para ser muy útiles por ejemplo piensa en una aplicación financiera todavía no hemos encontrado una
aceleración exponencial para la mayoría de los algoritmos financieros en los que podría usarse la computación cuántica pero eso no importa necesariamente no necesitamos una solución óptima
en finanzas al menos porque una solución que sea solo un 1% más eficiente podría equivaler a miles de millones de dólares
en ganancias entonces ¿cómo sabemos qué casos de uso y problemas podrían ser adecuados para la computación cuántica ahora mismo? y con eso
me refiero a que hay razones significativas para creer que la utilidad cuántica o incluso la ventaja cuántica podría encontrarse ya sea ahora o
en un futuro relativamente cercano quizás sea más fácil nombrar primero lo que el problema definitivamente no debe tener
no puede requerir un número enorme de qubits todavía no tenemos procesadores con miles o millones de qubits disponibles esa es una de las principales razones
por las que el algoritmo de Shor y similares están tan lejos los circuits tampoco pueden ser increíblemente profundos me resulta muy difícil
decirte exactamente qué profundidad de circuit no funcionará porque depende de muchos factores pero en general si tu
experimento requiere una profundidad que no has visto lograda en la literatura es posible que te espere un momento difícil y
por último cualquier tipo de algoritmo que sepamos que requerirá corrección de errores no puede hacerse todavía sin embargo lo que sí debemos buscar son experimentos que hagan
uso de la mayoría de los qubits disponibles en cualquier QPU dada también hemos destacado la
importancia de la mitigación y supresión de errores y por último debe haber una extensión obvia hacia aplicaciones futuras
que sean importantes para la sociedad y que pudiéramos ver eventualmente llevando a la ventaja
cuántica ahora hablemos de algunos ejemplos de casos de uso que se dividen en tres categorías principales que hemos
identificado como las más propensas a ver resultados favorables en el corto y mediano
plazo la primera área es la simulación de la naturaleza hemos hablado de esto anteriormente
hay muchísimas oportunidades para que los ordenadores cuánticos mejoren la investigación que se realiza a nivel molecular y atómico
y la razón de esto es que los métodos clásicos actuales están limitados por descripciones matemáticas fundamentalmente ineficientes
de las estructuras atómicas almacenar y manipular un estado cuántico requiere una cantidad exponencial de recursos
en una computadora clásica, pero sí de forma eficiente en una computadora cuántica, y eso es lo que hace que la simulación de materiales
y el modelado químico sean algunas de las áreas de aplicación más prometedoras. Más concretamente, esto podría llevar a
avances en la captura de dióxido de carbono, baterías alternativas o el desarrollo de nuevos fármacos. Algunos
algoritmos especialmente relevantes en esta área son el variational quantum eigensolver VQE, que se usa para
estimar ciertas propiedades de un material, como los estados de equilibrio o de energía mínima. Otro ejemplo es el
time dynamic simulation TDS, un algoritmo que se usa para estimar funciones de respuesta o propiedades espectrales de
materiales. Y también quería mencionar a un recién llegado: el sample-based quantum diagonalization, del que creemos que
vamos a oír hablar mucho más en el futuro cercano. La siguiente área de aplicación es la optimización. La optimización es bastante
ubicua en la computación, como te puedes imaginar, así que los casos de uso son bastante numerosos y variados.
Sin embargo, algunos ejemplos de los que se habla mucho son la optimización de portafolios en finanzas, el diseño industrial y también
la distribución y las cadenas de suministro. El algoritmo más común que probablemente escuches relacionado con la optimización es el que ya
hemos visto con cierta profundidad: el quantum approximate optimization algorithm, o
QAOA. Por último, un área que ha generado mucho entusiasmo en los últimos años es el quantum machine learning. Ahora bien,
creo que es justo decir que parece que el QML no va a llegar tan pronto como la simulación, con toda probabilidad, pero aun así hay
algunos algoritmos impresionantes en los que la gente trabaja de forma constante, correspondientes a casos de uso muy importantes.
Algunos de esos posibles casos de uso son el procesamiento del lenguaje natural, el análisis del tráfico de red e incluso la detección de fraude
en transacciones financieras. Los algoritmos relevantes en esta área son la quantum support vector
machine, las quantum neural networks y las quantum generative adversarial networks. Para aclarar, esos tres
grupos que acabamos de describir son áreas de aplicación amplias. También vale la pena señalar que en la comunidad hay
beneficios en que grupos que trabajan juntos estén enfocados en un tema específico. IBM impulsó una iniciativa no hace mucho
llamada The Working Groups, para ayudar a los colaboradores a encontrarse y crear sinergias productivas en cuatro áreas específicas:
salud y ciencias de la vida, materiales y HPC, física de altas energías y
optimización. Aquí están nuestros grupos actuales y las entidades involucradas en esos esfuerzos. Si quieres saber más sobre
lo que están haciendo los grupos de trabajo, hemos adjuntado cuatro de sus documentos técnicos en la descripción a continuación. Ahora bien, como dije,
creo que lo mejor en este punto del curso es dedicar algo de tiempo a explorar qué tipo de problemas está abordando la gente en la vanguardia
de esta tecnología, y desarrollar nuestra intuición para saber qué tipos de algoritmos van a funcionar y cómo
aplicarlos. Y antes de comenzar, quiero dejar muy claro que el objetivo principal aquí no es entender cada
detalle de los experimentos. Este tipo de análisis puede ser muy intimidante incluso para los expertos si el artículo está un poco
fuera de tu área de especialización. El objetivo es simplemente ayudar a desarrollar una intuición sobre los tipos de problemas que las computadoras
cuánticas resuelven bien y cómo manejarlos. Y si te interesan los detalles más finos y esto te ha generado
algunas ideas propias, te animo definitivamente a leer los artículos completos. Los casos de uso específicos y los
artículos que vamos a analizar en profundidad son los siguientes: primero, exploraremos un artículo que analiza la
simulación de la dinámica de hadrones. Esto cae en la categoría de física de altas energías. Luego veremos un problema de optimización,
concretamente la optimización cuántica contra-adiabática con campo de sesgo. Y por último, veremos otro problema de
simulación, pero esta vez centrado en el mRNA, una molécula crucial para el
desarrollo de fármacos y terapias. Tanto si conoces estos artículos como si no, no hay problema: vamos a repasar
los tres. Son artículos importantes que abordan problemas de tamaño considerable y muestran cómo las computadoras
cuánticas están empezando a usarse como otro método de investigación científica. El primero es la simulación de la dinámica de hadrones
y vamos a profundizar en un artículo del grupo de Martin Savage en la Universidad de Washington, titulado "Quantum
simulations of hadron dynamics in the Schwinger model using 112
qubits". Si no eres físico de altas energías, puede que aun así conozcas el término hadrón, como en el
Large Hadron Collider o LHC, el gigantesco acelerador de partículas de 27 kilómetros de circunferencia que hizo posible
observar finalmente el bosón de Higgs. Un hadrón es una partícula compuesta subatómica formada por otras partículas más pequeñas
llamadas quarks. Algunos ejemplos serían los neutrones y los protones. Para dar un poco de contexto, el LHC fue construido
para permitir el estudio de la física fundamental y lo que les ocurre a las partículas cuando colisionan a energías muy altas
en ese tubo circular. Con esto, los científicos esperan aprender más sobre cómo surgió el Universo primitivo.
Y como mencioné antes, también se usó para encontrar el bosón de Higgs, una partícula esquiva responsable de la masa de las
partículas fundamentales. Ahora bien, en principio, las interacciones de estas partículas podrían
simularse de principio a fin con una computadora cuántica suficientemente potente. Todavía no hemos llegado ahí, pero se está
progresando. El modelo de Schwinger es un modelo simple que se usa para simular parte de esta dinámica y se ha convertido en uno de
los modelos más populares. Los detalles del modelo no son muy importantes por ahora, pero para quienes tengan curiosidad,
es un modelo que describe el comportamiento de electrones y positrones interactuando mediante fotones en 1 + 1 D,
es decir, una dimensión espacial y el tiempo. El modelo tiene muchas similitudes con la cromodinámica cuántica,
que describe cómo interactúan los quarks y los hadrones. Eso es extremadamente difícil de simular, así que el
modelo de Schwinger se usa a menudo como modelo de juguete para investigar algunos fenómenos que son comunes a
ambos. Ahora bien, la forma en que vamos a proceder con este ejemplo y con el resto de los ejemplos que he seleccionado es
haciéndonos una serie de preguntas. La primera es: ¿por qué teníamos razones para creer que simular esto
en una computadora cuántica funcionaría? En este caso, los electrones y positrones del modelo de Schwinger tienen un efecto de blindaje
que hace que las correlaciones entre fotones distantes decaigan exponencialmente con la separación, y eso significa que no hay
tantas interacciones de largo alcance entre un qubit de un lado del chip y otro del lado opuesto,
lo que sabemos que es muy propenso a errores. Así que esto es realmente bueno para el hardware que tenemos disponible hoy. La siguiente pregunta es:
¿es este tema de interés? Bueno, espero haberte convencido ya de que sí, la física de altas energías es de gran
interés. La gente estuvo dispuesta a gastar miles de millones de dólares para construir el LHC, y miles de científicos y
técnicos de todo el mundo han dedicado sus vidas a este campo, así de importante es, pero el
modelo de Schwinger es simplista y no está diseñado para cubrir tres dimensiones espaciales. Sin embargo, es un
modelo importante ya que todavía proporciona cortes actualmente verificables y una simplificación útil de una teoría
completa. Por último, ¿cómo se realizó este trabajo o qué enfoque usarían si quisieran continuar el trabajo en
experimentos de tipo simulación? VQE es uno de los enfoques más comunes y el primer paso es casi siempre el mismo:
preparar el estado fundamental. En este caso es un estado de vacío, y en este experimento usan una nueva versión de VQE llamada SC-
adapt VQE para preparar tanto el estado fundamental como el paquete de onda del hadrón sobre el vacío. El siguiente paso es entonces
permitir que los hadrones evolucionen o se propaguen en el tiempo. Por último, necesitamos identificar los
observables que queremos detectar. Ahora bien, si esos pasos te sonaron algo familiares, exceptuando el paquete de onda del hadrón,
es porque estos pasos son muy similares a lo que cubrimos en el ejemplo de QAOA en el episodio anterior.
Esperemos que empieces a ver algunos patrones emergentes aquí. Los componentes necesarios para VQE son muy similares a los de QAOA.
Empezamos en un estado conocido, aquí el estado de vacío, y luego lo dejamos evolucionar en el tiempo con una serie de
hamiltonianos exponenciados divididos en partes manejables donde n es el número de divisiones. La única gran diferencia aquí
es que creamos el paquete de onda del hadrón centrado dentro de nuestro circuit antes de empezar a dejarlo evolucionar. Entonces, ¿cómo se
hace esto? Bueno, el estado de vacío es el estado fundamental y ya hemos cubierto de alguna forma cómo mapearlo. Ahora, preparar el paquete de onda del hadrón
es algo diferente. Sobre este vacío, un hadrón puede excitarse creando un par fermión-antifermión en
sitios adyacentes. Al preparar una superposición de tales hadrones en diferentes ubicaciones, se puede crear un paquete de onda
arbitrario. Los autores centraron su paquete de onda en el medio del circuit para observar la evolución
sin superar un límite. Pero recuerda que la clave cuando se trabaja con QPUs ruidosas es mantener la
profundidad del circuit manejable. Para esto, el protocolo SC-adapt VQE usa simetría y
jerarquías en escalas de longitud para determinar quantum circuits de baja profundidad para la preparación de estados. La idea es que esto
creará un ansatz con un número menor de parámetros, lo que equivale a una profundidad más reducida. Más detalles se pueden
encontrar en el artículo, más de lo que tenemos tiempo para cubrir aquí, así que asegúrate de revisarlo. Ahora echemos un vistazo a los resultados. Este experimento se ejecutó en
un dispositivo IBM Quantum Heron e implementó algunos tipos diferentes de mitigación y supresión de errores,
incluyendo una técnica más reciente llamada renormalización de decoherencia de operadores, así como desacoplamiento dinámico, extrapolación de ruido cero
y twirling polinomial. Ahora intentemos interpretar los datos. El observable que vamos a
medir para observar cómo se propaga el paquete de onda es algo llamado el condensado quiral, que es algo
abstracto, pero básicamente es una fase superfluida de los hadrones. Ahora podemos ver el paquete de onda centrado aquí en los
sitios designados para ejecutar este experimento, donde el color corresponde al condensado quiral. El
lado izquierdo muestra los resultados sin errores del simulador, mientras que el lado derecho muestra los resultados del computador cuántico IBM
Torino. Idealmente estas serían imágenes espejo una de la otra debido a la simetría, por lo que puedes ver que hay
algunas imperfecciones. Ahora este eje Y vertical corresponde a las partes de tiempo que
medí antes. Entonces, ¿por qué no hacemos algunos cortes horizontales a través del primer y último paso de tiempo de los datos para ver
qué le sucede al paquete de onda en el tiempo tau igual a 1? Aquí en naranja, correspondiendo a
este corte, puedes ver que el condensado quiral es estrecho y localizado. También corresponde muy bien con la
simulación que se hizo para comparación. En tau igual a 14, sin embargo, está mucho más disperso y es menos
localizado. Quizás la comparación con el simulador no es del todo perfecta ahora, pero todavía puedes ver claramente un muy buen acuerdo entre la teoría y los datos,
lo cual es alentador. En conclusión, este es un ejemplo muy interesante del tipo de trabajo de simulación en el que quizás no pensarías inicialmente
al aplicar computadores cuánticos. Sin embargo, de hecho puedes hacerlo y funciona. No es perfecto, pero no tienes que ser un
experto en física de partículas para ver que el computador cuántico predice con precisión la propagación hacia afuera del paquete de onda,
que es exactamente lo que esperaríamos encontrar. Con suerte, el trabajo futuro en esta área continuará y los físicos de alta energía
seguirán encontrando formas de incorporar la computación cuántica en sus flujos de trabajo. El objetivo es resolver problemas teóricos con más precisión,
aquellos que no se pueden resolver de forma clásica, y usar experimentos para aceptar o rechazar teorías con la esperanza de descubrir nueva
física, construir detectores mejorados y llegar a una mejor comprensión de la naturaleza en su nivel más fundamental.
Nuestro siguiente ejemplo se centra en la optimización y será un análisis profundo de un artículo llamado biased field
digitized counter-adiabatic quantum optimization, realizado por miembros del equipo de kipu quantum en la
Universidad del País Vasco en España. Empezaremos como lo hicimos antes
con una serie de definiciones. La primera es counter-adiabatic, que es un tipo de evolución que suprime los efectos no adiabáticos
que experimenta un sistema independientemente de lo rápido que ocurran esos procesos. Recuerda el teorema adiabático del
último episodio. Normalmente necesitas dejar que un sistema evolucione muy lentamente si deseas que permanezca en el estado fundamental.
Este es un gran problema porque cuanto más lentamente tenemos que dejar que las cosas evolucionen, más tiempo tenemos para que ocurran errores.
El manejo counter-adiabatic, a menudo abreviado como CD, tiene como objetivo combatir esto
añadiendo términos que contrarrestan estas excitaciones no deseadas. La idea principal aquí es acelerar todo el experimento y
reducir la profundidad del quantum circuit suprimiendo las excitaciones que podrían llevar a transiciones
espurias. Ahora hablemos de qué es un campo de sesgo. Otros algoritmos iterativos como VQE toman parámetros clásicos en
estos estados y usan optimizadores clásicos para buscar en el espacio de parámetros multidimensional ese conjunto
que produce un valor de expectación mínimo para un hamiltoniano fijo. En este caso, en cambio, varían el hamiltoniano en cada
paso, moviéndose adiabáticamente desde un caso conocido al caso de interés. Pero dado que no se están pasando parámetros clásicos
y no hay función de onda variacional, ¿cómo actualizas tu estado de un paso al hamiltoniano al siguiente? Bueno,
añaden un campo de sesgo al hamiltoniano. Cualquiera que sea el estado de menor energía de la ejecución anterior, añaden un término en el
hamiltoniano para sesgar el estado a favor de ese. Entonces, ¿por qué es interesante este experimento?
Bueno, en primer lugar, este es un nuevo enfoque que podría aplicarse de forma más general a otros problemas de optimización,
pero en este caso lo aplicaron a un problema de vidrio de espín de Ising. Como comentamos anteriormente, muchos combinatoriales
los problemas de optimización se pueden reformular como la búsqueda de estados de baja energía de hamiltonianos de Ising; el modelo de
Ising es una serie de espines microscópicos distribuidos en un arreglo; el modelo puede usarse para describir un vidrio de espín en el que
la magnetización está desordenada: básicamente, los pequeños momentos magnéticos están orientados aleatoriamente en el arreglo, y
¿por qué pensamos que esto funcionaría bien? Ya vimos en parte cómo estamos combatiendo dos problemas típicos que se encuentran en los
algoritmos variacionales cuando cubrimos las definiciones del artículo; pero para resumir el algoritmo, ellos
proponen acelerar la evolución para reducir la profundidad del circuit y al mismo tiempo suprimir las transiciones no adiabáticas;
además, no depende de ninguna rutina de optimización clásica, lo que puede ser un problema que lleve a mesetas de Barren
y a quedar atrapado en mínimos locales; por último, los autores también se aseguran de alinear las interacciones del hamiltoniano del problema
con la conectividad del hardware en la QPU real, lo que siempre es muy importante; por último, ¿cómo funciona esto? Pues bien,
como dije, aquí no se usan optimizadores clásicos, a diferencia de lo que ocurre habitualmente en los algoritmos cuánticos iterativos;
en cambio, al alimentar la solución de cada iteración como entrada para la siguiente, el algoritmo de optimización cuántica digitalizada con campo de sesgo
refina el estado base de forma incremental, acercándolo cada vez más al
estado evolucionado final; y combinado con protocolos contra-adiabáticos, podemos hacer esto incluso con circuits cuánticos de poca profundidad
que deberían ejecutarse sin problemas en hardware ruidoso; así que cuando se realizó el experimento, los autores eligieron ejecutar el
algoritmo en la computadora cuántica IBM de 127 qubit Brisbane; aquí el autor mostró
la etización del algoritmo de optimización para una instancia de vidrio de espín generada aleatoriamente con vecinos más próximos
sobre 100 qubit; comparan los resultados de simulación ideal de DCQ y BF-DCQ
así como el resultado experimental, y también muestran un resultado de un solver clásico llamado Gurobi como referencia; ahora bien,
con tan solo 10 iteraciones, BF-DCQ ofrece una mejora drástica comparada con
DCQ; aunque el resultado experimental difiere un poco del resultado ideal debido al ruido, el rendimiento sigue siendo
mejor que el DCQ ideal; esto muestra que todavía se están logrando excelentes avances en materia de
optimización cuántica, y se están reportando buenos resultados con más de 100 qubit por primera vez
en muchos aspectos; por último, pero no menos importante, hay un artículo muy interesante que explora la predicción de la estructura del ARNm, de nuestros amigos en
Moderna Pharmaceuticals, y se llama "Predicción de la estructura secundaria del ARNm usando computadoras cuánticas a escala utilitaria";
para empezar, si, como yo, llevas varios años sin tomar un curso de biología, puedes refrescar qué es
el ARNm: el ARN mensajero es un tipo de ARN involucrado en la síntesis de proteínas;
básicamente lee las instrucciones dadas por el ADN; la estructura secundaria del ARNm es, más o menos, cómo se pliega la cadena, y
el problema de la predicción de la estructura secundaria del ARN es el problema de encontrar el plegamiento más estable de la secuencia
de bases de nucleótidos que forman el ADN y el ARN, es decir, C, G, U y A; esta
imagen muestra algunas de las estructuras de plegamiento comunes que se encuentran en el ARNm; cada color resaltado aquí muestra una
estructura secundaria diferente; pero las características exactas que hacen que una de estas estructuras sea más favorable que
otra no se comprenden bien; todo lo que podemos hacer es averiguar cuál tiene la menor energía libre en comparación con el
estado no plegado, y ahí es donde entran las computadoras cuánticas; ¿por qué son importantes las estructuras secundarias del ARNm?
Pues bien, la predicción precisa de ellas es en realidad crucial no solo para entender el ADN y nuestros genes, sino también
para diseñar terapéuticos basados en ARN, como la vacuna contra el COVID-19; hay razones para creer que el enfoque de
este artículo funcionaría porque durante mucho tiempo se ha sabido que este es un formidable problema de optimización para las
computadoras clásicas, debido a la enorme cantidad de configuraciones posibles; y para algunas configuraciones, se sabe que es
un problema NP-completo; sin embargo, en una computadora cuántica podemos formular la predicción de la estructura secundaria como un
problema de optimización binaria, algo que sabemos cómo manejar; además, ya existe evidencia en la literatura
de predicción precisa del ARN en dispositivos cuánticos de pequeña escala y en simuladores cuánticos; así que la pregunta obvia es:
¿funcionaría esto en hardware más grande? El experimento se realiza usando algo llamado el valor condicional
en riesgo del solver cuántico variacional de eigenstates (CVaR-VQE), que es una modificación al algoritmo VQE tradicional y se espera que
logre una mejor convergencia; esta gráfica muestra la distribución de las probabilidades de medición
de las cadenas de bits de la muestra con las energías correspondientes para una instancia de 42
nucleótidos y 80 qubit; aquí las cadenas de bits simbolizan los emparejamientos de los
nucleótidos; ilustra que la cadena de bits de menor energía tiene un valor de energía de -140, que coincide con la
cadena de bits de menor energía encontrada por el solver clásico comparativo; así que eso es genial, y esta es la estructura plegada óptima
de esa cadena de nucleótidos basada en la cadena de bits de menor energía que ha encontrado el hardware;
y con eso hemos llegado al final de este episodio; mi intención aquí no era abrumarte con
detalles de distintos artículos de investigación; como dije, simplemente quería darte el contexto suficiente para que entiendas cómo es
el trabajo de vanguardia en el campo ahora mismo; la esperanza es que esto haga girar algunos engranajes en la
cabeza de todos, y que al ver cómo otros abordan los problemas, puedas hacer conexiones y tener la
confianza para intentar nuevos experimentos cuánticos que quizás antes no te hubieras atrevido; y oye, puede que algunos no
funcionen, y está bien, para eso es la investigación; de ahora en adelante, recuerda que los tipos de problemas que nos
interesan se pueden agrupar por metodología o por tema, y hemos trazado los que creemos que son
los más prometedores a corto plazo; recuerda que la computación cuántica no sirve para todo, y esto es simplemente un
testimonio de lo buenos que nos hemos vuelto en la computación clásica; el hecho de que creas que podrías aplicar la computación cuántica
a un problema no significa que vaya a dar resultados interesantes; por desgracia, tienes que considerar la escala; la profundidad del circuit
es un arma de doble filo: necesitamos que sea considerablemente grande para hacer trabajo interesante que las computadoras
clásicas no puedan hacer; pero ahora mismo, debido al ruido del hardware, no podemos empujarla a tamaños enormes porque la fidelidad
disminuirá; todo se trata de encontrar ese punto óptimo y saber que es un objetivo en movimiento; así que tómate un tiempo entre
este episodio y el próximo para pensar de verdad en algunos problemas que hayas encontrado y en cómo querrías abordarlos con lo que hemos
aprendido hasta este punto; sé creativo y no te limites; y si tienes alguna idea, aunque creas que es un poco
descabellada, dímela en los comentarios de abajo; gracias por ver y hasta la próxima